are you drinking alcohol like old school
out all that was mixed media distillery
or a winery or something like that that
is old school get news cool people
it's now in powdered form the alcohol
tobacco tax and trade Bureau has
approved
how cahall which is a powdered alcoholic
drink mix
for sale and distribution I am basically
it's exactly what it sounds like it's
basically Kool Aid
that you just add some water too and you
can get smashed
I believe we have a an image if sum up
the packaging
they're quitting get up at cosmopolitan
a mojito a powder reader
which barely taste just like a margarita
and a lemon drop amongst the couple
others
and that there's been some confusion on
the internet whether this was approved
or was an approved which seems like it
up to a bit
up debate the labels I guess had been
approved yet
the but the would you drink powdered
alcohol is this the future is everything
gonna be in powdered form
I feel very conflicted because I don't
drink by love novelty items
so I feel like I kinda wanna have the
power out hardest because it's
ridiculous and Mike
you know it's a thing to do right would
you snort the powdered alcohol
if you don't drink as a non drinker yeah
that's a good to call
yes not at I like making a face mask I
love it
yes reverend your skin yeah I'll or
paste
whatever it takes whatever islamic a
drink it not gonna drink it
as the jack anything that makes the
making jungle juice for college parties
easier is going to succeed
so I I can imagine I i think the prank
potential a powdered alcoholism really
high
you know just like your friends away
like it's finally a fun surprise to
leave in someone's drink you know not a
dangerous one so
you know you leave a little powdery to
in there and
they get a nice little surprise as
they're having brunch we're going to bed
you know I can see college kids across
america it's the new
the new trend on campus yes remember a
couple was it like a year ago there was
gonna be beer that was just a vapor and
you could just get wasted like that
people always fight this stuff but you
really can't fight progress can you want
okay
if people want to have a little packet
the powdered booze they're never right
now everything will be okay
yeah of relative sprinkling alcohol on
your feet I was a flavor enhancer
or just to get drunk on fries whatever
it takes to get margarita french fries
yet 1 I'm get drunk at the same time
that router not a terrible seem like the
future actually
yeah I'm soft the do you think they're
gonna have
you know alternate companies they're
gonna start cutting it was tough you
look at these there's a drug element
to this you know it I mean where you
gonna get the purest up and then it's
going to be cut with some
nice and rain or something right
gasoline gasoline whatever it is that
yeah it's just I'd I mean we really have
the equivalent I'm sure these things
just taste like bad
it but Wine Mixer was basically like
that brings the things they sell in like
pouches
at you know cies I was there all the
wine cooler brand like from the 80's
those two guys there's 20 guys
portals in vials in jail here in Table
II exactly so it's just it's
that's my one problem with is like do
you need another step towards alcohol
like has anybody ever been like man I
love drinking
but if only there was another
preparatory step between me and getting
drunk
right I don't think that's stopping you
it's actually better because you think
about it you know what you would have
another drink but I really wanna open
this how to pack it
and mix it with water right way at that
time could it also be the river so that
like where people want to get drunk
easily let's say you're at a baseball
game and you don't want to pay 12 bucks
for a beer you can go ago I got a bottle
of water
lax about what I cause a but they are
you bring your own water right and then
iranians although it's a crystallite so
financially it makes sense
share if you were the month idea but
I've just never
had like Kool Aid and thought to myself
like man I what hap
kool aid more like I want this to expand
into other
areas of my life and so I don't the idea
I've making alcoholic who live
doesn't exactly give you told me like
hey I made a bunch alcoholic cool they
would you like some I would definitely
say no
you will not try that so is this really
though this seems to me that this is
really about kids drinking
the know that's where the you know like
a can of course there are marketed to
adult
but the people that are really gonna be
smuggling packets it the parties and to
family a bed gonna be Kate so there is
some risk I wanna package like Pixie
Stix
we could have a and the whole and I will
open minded find it even better
up that would be there thinking outside
the box yet that no use it as alcoholic
funded that actually is the best
that sounds great another white sugar
sticks and
yeah I'm in should be P be concerned
about the kids the kids
well you know it because I always think
that someone has to be heard about the
kids you no matter what your name from
simpson's
yeah luxuries like the word about did it
does seem a
like this will be a very shoplifted item
layer is much easier to go into a store
in grab a little pouch of something and
that will fit in anybody's pocket that
alike
grab a bunch of bottles them as a kid
like pocket for powder
just like grabbing and portable hardware
and walking around just like leaving a
trail of
Palka hall behind them yeah it just has
so much better so many occasions alcohol
not good right
sounds like a department of like pals
and alcohol which
already is like out now the I will maybe
the
pack a whole people have some marking
issues to work on least I got to get the
labels approved everything so we will
see
what happened then when it becomes legal
we would read it here do official taste
test